before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it don't forget to like the
video on your way in and if you have
watched two or more of my lives and you
do not subscribe we have beef okay beef
people so um a couple announcements the
first being we have two clips channels
the first is called Pearl daily and the
second is called just pearly Clips make
sure you subscribe to those because you
guys got us to 10K in two weeks and then
50k in a month on the other one yay
um on top of that make sure you sign up
for our memberships the first tier is a
five dollar tier that allows us to be
you to be a part of the chap this live
stream the second one is the 10 tier
this is a cool Penthouse right guys it's
cool if you guys want to see what the
penthouse looks like makes make sure you
subscribe you can see behind the scenes
scenes footage and you also get to see
our cool reaction area we are going to
be doing all different types of content
in this Penthouse so make sure you sign
up the third tier is to connect with us
on social media in the fourth tier is
you get a one-on-one call with me once a
month some people use this to you know
tell me their life problems you know
I'll give you advice
and the second and other people use it
for YouTube help um I I'm actually I
kill it on YouTube help I've helped so
many people get 10 20 30k Subs so make
sure you sign up for that as well
um also my Instagram is shadowband right
now so make sure you type in just dot
pearly things that you have to type in
the whole thing for my name to come up
but I'm almost a 50k on Instagram also
they took away my first ticket Tick Tock
account they took away my second Tick
Tock account they took away my third
Tick Tock account but they can't get rid
of me I'm on my fourth Tick Tock account
and we got 100K on it
um so that's just.perly things dot or
just dot pearly things four and just dot
pearlythings5 is my fifth account and
make sure you go follow that because
um I'm kind of afraid they're gonna take
away account number four so
um on top of that we have a members only
live stream we are going to be doing in
two weeks so make sure you sign up for
our memberships that is when me Jess our
producer we will be having you know
conversations we'll talk about like our
favorite show moment and you know other
behind the scenes looks so make sure you
sign up for that
um if you want to come on the show DM
Eddie the link to his Instagram is in
the description
so um today we have a lovely panel um so
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact
okay my name's Robin I'm 31 I'm single
and
fun facts you put me on spot now um if
you Shrunk the world down to the size of
a cue ball it would be as smooth as a
cue ball
okay well I would let him know okay
hi my name is Esther I am 34. I am
single and I'm not searching and you're
not searching I'm not searching do you
wanna do you want to like buy a dog and
die alone
you said you're not searching how else
how else would you seeking me
I just I just I just thought you like
weren't trying to get in a relationship
at all so you you're not you're not
looking but they're looking for you yeah
oh okay okay
and a fun fact is
uh I love to roller skate
um
yeah
hi I'm Joe I'm 33 I'm married
um and a fun fact is when I was 17 I
wrapped with Coolio in his studio in
Harley Street
that's cool
but I can't rap
I was drunk okay I was gonna say I'm a
rapper so like we could we could rap
together yeah if you want it I've had
bars then but I don't definitely die in
a bath now okay if you guys want to see
me rapping sign up for the 10 tier on
our behind the scenes walk swear to God
I swear to God if you don't believe me
sign up 10 bucks a month you get to see
me rap your own raps or just a long too
no I was freestyling yeah yeah I got I
got bars yeah a lot of bars I want to
see that so many bars I can't do we get
to see
um you know what I don't want friends I
don't see I don't want to intimidate you
so uh yeah
go ahead
all right so it's King riches you
already know YouTube and listen I upset
a lot of people on social media that's
my fun fact that's all I got to say
sorry
yeah if you know you know what what
happened to you on Tick Tock I said uh
what is it just a normal preference a
standard dating preference for a man and
you know a lot of ladies were upset
about that you can't have a preference
as a man you're not allowed to breathe
as a man like so you know I've got a
little bit of heat for that but it's
okay I'm shocked
I smoothed it out
okay go ahead
um um
37 years I've been taken away from the
dating scene and um even taken away yeah
who why I'm no longer available for
dating oh okay you're in a relationship
we give you news help I'm good and
um fun fact is um I'm a digital music
producer and a registered nurse those
are two divers different fields okay you
could produce my rap album
[Laughter]
so um today's topic is what does a
healthy relationship look like and why
has our generation got it so wrong
so
um any answers to that question off the
top of your head let's go around
I don't feel like I'm the best person to
start this because I'm not in a
relationship so uh heavy relationships
are tended to fail
um the best I've ever managed is two
years but I think that um
one of the like every relationship has
been a learning experience so I've
learned something about what not to do
in a relationship which gets me closer
to what you should do in a relationship
and I think some of the big
the the biggest failure for my most
recent relationship I think
is that we didn't have enough arguments
we tended to work too hard to please
each other and just let things slide to
keep the other person happy
okay
um I think sex is not sacred anymore and
that's really contributing to a lot of
damage
yeah okay
okay I think that these days people are
some people are very quick to
um throw things that could potentially
be good away
um I think with marriage and
relationships
it's hard work it does take commitment
it takes a lot of work and I think these
days people think are the grass is green
on the other side whereas back in the
day that wasn't you know people worked
hard for something to make something
work and they put a lot in and it was
more frowned upon to leave
a a marriage and
um I think sometimes people think it's a
bit disposable these days so they're not
putting they're not willing to put the
hard work in as much why do people the
average marriage I believe is either
seven years or nine years why do people
leave so quick do you think as a when
you know like women from the 1920s 30s
40s like they would stay even if their
man had a family across town yeah yeah
I think
these days
[Music]
um
we are kind of sold this dream that
everything is perfect or it can be
better we've got you know very high
expectations these days I talked to my
nan like she's she's dead now but when I
used to talk to her she said oh no we
were seeing it through for you know the
long haul it wasn't something that we
would just give up on and um I think
these days things are are a lot more
disposable like people think
everything's like a far away thing like
more and I think marriage is hard work
like I've been married now for
eight years together for nine and a half
and there are times where it hasn't been
perfect and we've both like had to work
really hard we've put Graft in and we've
come through the other side stronger but
if there were times when we probably
both could have said oh you know I
forget this let's you know but and when
you got married did you have the mindset
that you don't believe in divorce yeah
because I I just saw Jordan Peterson
talk last night and he said that one
thing
um
that makes like people are so quick to
divorce because they believe in it where
and like every time they have a part a
fight with their partner their thought
is am I going to leave where before it
was how would we work this out yeah so I
think I'm not an advocate for staying in
a marriage where it's there's abuse
sorry I'm not Advocate advocate for
people staying in a um marriage that is
abusive or toxic especially if they're
children involved however I think there
are a lot of things that people can work
through and
um
yeah I basically think that there are
things that you definitely can work
through and people aren't willing to put
that work in
um but
I mean there are relationships that I
think kids are better off not seeing if
it's really toxic if it's abusive then
I'm all for it get out of it if it's you
know but it doesn't always mean that the
grass is going to be greener on the
other side
um or better for the children but um
yeah I'm all about putting and have you
seen any of your friends that got
divorced and they realized it wasn't
Greener
um or someone that you know
yes I have seen I mean yeah family
friends that have you know at the time
thought this is the best thing but been
a lot unhappier when they've got out of
it
um I mean for example my mum and dad I
came from a parent a single parent
family they split up when I was four and
I remember the day that they split up
and I was I was happy when they split up
because it was a toxic relationship and
I remember my mom telling me I'm feeling
really really happy that they were gonna
split up but I do think
um there are a lot of relationships that
you could have put the work in and you
could have you could have come out the
other side because you know I've looked
at friends even gone through cheat and
stuff and come out the other side
because they've been willing to put
um the work in and have the faith to
kind of get through it
okay what do you think Michael
okay all right repeat can you repeat the
question
um what does a healthy relationship look
like and why does our generation get it
so wrong
okay I'll say one of the primary things
is that a lot of us we come from
backgrounds where we didn't have like a
stable like Mom and Dad a lot of us
don't know the Dynamics of making a
relationship work I know I don't most of
the people I grew up with with boys or
girls came from single parent families
so if you haven't grown up and been like
kind of conditioned to see okay this is
how you cooperate this is how you get
over obstacles blah blah blah you know
it's not always going to be rainbows and
happy times sometimes it's going to be
you know we're bored or it's just like
monotony and stuff like that we haven't
really seen that also another thing is
like there's so many options so like
just like what you were saying about the
grasses green and stuff like that a lot
of times you know you're looking on
Instagram you're scrolling scrolling
scrolling you're looking you're looking
at what your friends are doing and stuff
like that or whoever you look at as a
role model if they're going on like you
know holidays every week going to
hakkasan and novel cough and all these
places and then you're just going
Nando's every week you might not even go
Nando's you know what I'm saying you
might just be eating TV dinner and
you're gonna be like bro like this is
dead like I've had enough like so I
think the internet has got a uh yeah 100
um and yeah unrealistic expectations as
well so that kind of goes hand in hand
with the what I just said you know
people are just like oh I want to live
this rock star life that's not real life
you know our grandparents and even like
our parents knew that like you know I
mean there was a there was a sense of
Duty like to get what I'm saying it's
more about family like and and the
family growing and building an empire
where everyone just wants to everyone
wants to just do it for the gram you
know I'm saying like so you know and uh
yeah that's about it that's all I see I
think in response to that that um the
social media element like and the media
in general there wouldn't have been a
few decades ago it would have been
considered a source of shame that your
relationship has failed and you if you
were getting divorced
any attention to that would be negative
and now it's sort of seen as uh
empowerment you know it is um we see
celebrities getting divorced and it's
like good for them they've they've left
this relationship and social social
media one thing but usually it's women
that do that but women initiate more
divorces than men yeah in general yeah
so it's like you go girl you go and you
go somewhere and the the social media
the falseness of social media you will
get people who leave relationships when
they're posting all over social media
how happy they are to have left their
relationship but what they're not
posting is the pictures of them crying
the second they put their phone down
you're getting drunk like yeah getting
drunk and eating ice cream bro well in
their eggs
have you ever been in a bar in the girls
bathroom and it's like
it sounds like the girls are more
generous than the guys
there will be people in the bathroom
doing lines but they don't offer them
rounds
um a healthy relationship should have
um its members having good conflict
resolution skills
a lot of
couples today just just fight and and
just keep fighting and there's nothing
that they are trying to achieve from the
fight you know just want to be that I'm
the winner I'm I'm getting the better of
the other person
um there should be a lot of mutual
respect
um it's also a good idea to be
um very um
what's the word now um considerate of
the of the other person
um why are the youths getting it wrong
um there's a there's an influence of the
internet and media
um the the media kind of tells young
guys today that young guys and girls
today that they should give in to their
sexual instincts
um yeah that it's okay to do that it's
okay as a man to see a lady and the
thing that you should be appreciating
about the lady is a outward figure yes
oh I like well it starts with that
I agree that attraction starts from
there but I disagree that that should be
the focus I disagree that there should
be that there is
a focus on that in the media if the
media is saying that oh this lady looks
nice or this guy looks nice but let's
look at this other part of the lady then
I agree that okay yeah but that's that's
not what happens the media says nothing
absolute to zero zero point zero about
character in a relationship zero about
integrity nothing
okay I think there's there's no
discussion about that in in media and
the children are going in that direction
they see that that's what we are
supposed to be looking out for in in
relationships so materialistic yeah
great yeah like face value
I mean I did say
a very short statement which was sexist
too available
and I recently was reading huh sex is
very available for you for everybody no
no that's not that's that that's not
true what no no one out of one out of
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
under 30. because they are aiming for a
when if they settled for D no no I
promise you no
statistically women women far easier to
have sex find sex and it's only a small
percentage you get the majority of women
even even women that are very
unattractive are still very picky of
course yeah right so that's what I'm
saying if they're picky they're not
picking a large percentage of men the
standard has dropped there are more
women in situationships
right but with a with a small percentage
of men so like the reason they think
like men are trash is because they're
all screwing the same ones so so it's
like it's like a very small percentage
of men are screwing everybody's yeah it
is on Tinder just sitting in their house
waiting to get tapped into the game so
they can be that guy as well yeah for
the statistics for Tinder uh men swipe
uh is it right yes
right 60 of the time whereas women swipe
right three percent of the time exactly
so it's like they're very very selective
compared to men yeah
how many guys have moved to you this
week
[Laughter]
but I feel like the way guys present
themselves they are not they they are
reflecting a reality that is not so them
because guys act like yeah I get girls
yes
that's not that's not true it's only the
guys you pay attention to that yeah it's
only the guys you pay attention to
because
you don't you don't you don't notice the
guy at Nando's working I'm sorry yeah
like it's disingenuous it's just it's
just I mean you say thank you but you're
not really checking for him thinking
does he get girls you know deep down he
doesn't you know and like women we just
know this stuff and you can you could
walk into a room you as a girl you know
who's getting laid you know who's
knocking you don't have to sit they
don't have to say [ __ ] you know who's
telling the truth
and around with guys they're they're
although there are plenty of guys who
don't do this there is a percentage of
guys who massively inflate the idea of
how many girls
that's you're you're not wrong but like
I I went to like a pickup boot camp once
and it's basically where they teach guys
how to get laid and so I could see I
could see the uh the extremes it was
really interesting it was kind of like
like seeing what they teach the boys
they have them here too yeah yeah
um it's it's a very big kids
no it's a really big Community like they
they pay thousands of dollars to fly
into a city yeah and and learn from guys
that know how to get laid how to get
laid
okay because that's how that's how like
lonely they are but because they they
don't even know what it's like to have a
girl like look at them and be in they
don't even know what it's like to have a
girl excited to talk to them because we
don't we don't feel that guy and you're
on eight figures
yeah the thing is yeah on the real one
yeah it's all laughing and joking but
that's real to them that's their life
you look like a laughing joke because
you don't even understand that life no I
do like no no because you you you you
some degree if you you know what it's
like to get rejected by a small
percentage of guys but you don't know
what it's like to get rejected by
everybody because you know you try no
more yeah you know if you walk outside
like they don't even if you walk outside
and say anyone have sex with me you'll
have takers
yeah but you know what I'm saying like
those guys if they said that they would
be looked at like they're crazy and they
probably have the police called yeah 100
out or sections right and that's and
that's the thing at that boot camp I
could see very extreme ends because you
had the guys that were teaching the boot
camp that get laid all the time and the
guys that were going that that didn't
that didn't even know how to talk to me
like I couldn't even have a non like
they could barely have a conversation
with me were they nervous yeah yeah
they're awkward I mean some like oh my
gosh I have stories from like this one
guys this one guy was telling me how
he's gonna conquer the world
like he wanted to be like uh you know
that's that's a different thing but
there is some
um
yeah and it was but the the instructors
I saw them take
probably five girls home in three days
come on yeah five girls and so and so
each of those girls would think that
she's on the instructor's level but I I
mean they weren't all pretty sorry but
they were there men and men and women
there to pick up oh come on you need a
you need a you need a class do you go
outside and say does anyone want to have
sex just do this
you just need to arrive just eat it it's
true just just stand up for real
does she have a vagina is the
qualification no I mean the girls on my
300 pound life they still got a man
I'm still single yeah but that's a
choice though
friend zone saying my friend zone is
popping what's up guys oh my God oh my
God
um
yes oh friends I have a dungeon for them
okay when they try to keep escaping I
put them in the block dungeon why why
don't you why don't you just cut them
off and tell them it's never gonna
happen yeah that's why they're in the
dungeon they when you go over that
boundary of it's not gonna happen and
you still troop kind of come at me I put
you in prison which is the dungeon on
the block list of WhatsApp do they
consent to this they don't they just
they're in the doctor they have no idea
you're in prison now like you don't
yeah but then annually twice a year I
have like parole reviews
for a lifetime do you not see what a
privileged position that is in the
sexual Marketplace to be in a position
where you're just blocking people and
choosing if you want to go back to them
but the thing is it's draining it is
very draining I hadn't been trying to
have seen it since I was 12. it is I'm
I'm tired we have a wonder you realize
one day it's gonna go away and you're
gonna miss it because no one's checking
for girls at 50. my mom is quite pretty
and she's 63. she's good looking okay
well I've got leeway but I get what
you're saying your sexual market value
does it decrease as you get older yeah
so it's like like one one day you're
gonna be like I missed the cat calls
cat calls every year though like I'm
getting old you'll be like where's the
key to that dungeon
fact and you're gonna be like oh I
remember when I was on that podcast and
I was talking a load of crap
stay out of their place in that dungeon
why why did they end up in the dungeon
why
Sam just wanted sex for me I don't want
that
so why don't you just cut them off
completely blocked like that and they
kept coming back how how no I told you
some make parole because I give you a
second chance so basically I'm not
actually cutting them off I don't talk
to them I unblock them they don't know
they're unblocked it's only if they
maybe
my status I'm just thinking like I don't
want to hold people in my dungeon I want
to release the peace attention is
currency that's why I don't care about I
don't want
my opinion is that why are literally
talking to guys that when you are in
such a situation yeah move out of that
situation I do but sometimes I'm saying
that we guys should talk to other guys
you know if a lady is telling you um no
yes all right later I'll talk to you
later and you move on not even talk too
late just end yeah
so I have a question yeah you said that
sex is too readily available yes okay so
like what
don't you think like the only way to
make it unreadly available is to get
married young agreed okay 100 agreed and
to state
your goal because a lot of people are
dating without a definitive intention
yeah and we're having this conversation
there's no courtship anymore dating and
courtship are two different courtship
means
um marriage is the goal we'd like to get
there let's figure out how to navigate
our way on this journey to reach the end
goal whereas dating is like
The Crystal Maze yeah you might open and
there might be a trap door you might
fall down a well
is it a woman's photo I think that we're
both sexes are contributing to this
issue and women are on this I'm a
feminist sexual freedom and the truth is
they are they're not happy yeah they're
missing them but they don't want to
admit that they're not happy because
then to admit that would mean that
actually you've been changed [ __ ] for
the last 10 years but they're not ready
to let that go so I think women as well
just be honest you're not enjoying the
experience you're not enjoying the
experience biologically do you know when
you have sex as a woman something called
the limbic system makes you connect
emotionally to a man that is biological
that even if you say yeah no feelings
I'm just lashing and dashing
if he hits that wait let me look at the
character he hits that spot
no you will connect if you keep doing
something over and over again it becomes
habit that's human behavior you will
have to some degree if wait bearing in
mind if she likes your personality yeah
she will emotionally connect with you
yeah if she likes you even if you've got
whack PP if she commits
she won't cheat because she wants excuse
me
he's probably not the first guy that
she's beat bro yeah so she's probably
beat a man before that was pretty good
yeah she's had the Tyrone before she had
eight inches before Tyrone is doing it
so like if my man yeah he's got creep
personality he makes you laugh but every
time it's bedtime he's got the Shadows
here we go Deliver Me From Evil all it
takes is the next Tyrone to call you up
it depends on the girl though no it
depends on the girl I know a girl who's
working with freaking inches they got
four kids and she's in she loves him
she's accepted that he's not gonna blow
the back out she hasn't got the high
expectations
for girls if a girl's with a guy and
it's not if she doesn't think it's the
best she can do they usually leave after
they get the kids or what the resources
that they want I'm not gonna lie the guy
takes care of her they're really good
friends they have excellent
communication I think she's seen that
you know yeah
so he's probably doing a cuckold no no
she has sex with him
three kids I met a girl I met a girl in
a similar situation yeah yeah and the
girl hollered me
to blow her back out in front of her
boyfriend and her boyfriend's like yeah
cause you can't Supply the goods I had
their surgeries wait wait wait wait what
oh yeah and I said I told this story
before I haven't told this story before
come on okay so so basically so how did
this start how did you get her number
so I'm at University last year my first
Festival in fact I'm referred to you and
I'm like you know what if I go back to
the ends I ain't gonna get a chance to
do Festival things I did the festival
thing we're not getting it you know yeah
you're from nuts yes I went to detonate
see this girl twerking in the middle of
the freaking field I'm thinking what I'm
gonna go catch that wine hey yeah so
I'll leave everyone like the way I'm
catching that way boom it's a nice time
to you know what the dance has done so
your balance we telling me what's going
on right now she was my boyfriend's
behind you
I said what who left it there that's the
end of that story
a few years down the line yeah it's it's
uh no not yet well actually no I'm in
second year it's third year now next
year
um we're having a house party freshest
week I get a text on my phone I open up
I see a nude it's like Eddie want to
come over
we ain't spoken you know bearing your
mind I've seen I've seen the larger rate
the skills look I said yeah and I'm
drunk I'm finished it's fresh this week
so she's like listen I've already owed
you on Uber it's outside wow seriously
yeah so as I'm driving I'm getting more
news come free but what I'm not
realizing is that she's not the one
holding the camera
[Music]
so I've I've arrived at this destination
yeah and I've seen a girl come in a big
jacket obviously nothing underneath and
then I walk in I see a guy doing coconut
corner I'm not wait so hello my name's
obviously I call them Tony
I'll call him Tony he's a teacher
they're both School teachers the game's
all [ __ ] up
so he's we're just talking now we're
getting to know each other
how many teachers
like loads of teachers during the
holidays it's crazy it was it was a mad
situation so me and this guy were just
talking about reasoning that he's
offered me a drink we're getting to know
each other do you know what I mean so
then
Matt has come to get the business the
girls backed off the jacket now and he's
just like yeah I went to [ __ ] my
girlfriend what yeah did they film it no
no no no no prick
but then yeah like then just lead into
it you get me and he watched them and he
watched he was just in the corner just
watching was he in a closet
that's what I think I think he's got
erectile dysfunction oh okay so he's
just sitting he's just he's just I don't
know what he's trying to do in the
corner but nothing nothing's working so
yeah like that that happened so you were
basically rent a dick
she definitely cheated
he was consensual you know he wanted it
I got two little holes in your story
though you said you just danced with her
and then left when she said yeah you had
she had your number yes and she knew
where to send the Uber she knows my
friend
they started together University so she
knows my boy obviously I cut the story
down but she knows my way and they know
they know each other's friends so boom
that's how she really she actually went
to an effort to hunt you down we had
each other off these times Facebook was
sort of thing so we still saw each other
on Facebook so there's still like we I
kind of knew she was there type thing
but to me she had a boyfriend she's
taken whatever so when she's holding my
boy now I said oh my boy's country and
said yo you know someone so interested
in you I'm like yeah
left it there and then the text come
through and I was like okay now it's
time to get to business
talk to me
please what would you rate her out of
ten she was actually good food you know
like give me your number though because
I need to know I'm I'm gonna say can we
use seven she's a solid 7.5 because yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what was her
boyfriend what was the boyfriend yeah
he was an attractive guy do you know he
looked a lot like my man
she haunted me again
like a subscription type thing but you
know what like it was weird didn't it so
like when I sobered up that's when I was
thinking like raw that was actually a
mad situation so I didn't really go back
there he did he still Hollows me to this
day he tries to introduce me to new
women he's got another girlfriend
honestly he will send me nudes and be
like my girlfriend wants black Willy
how
do I feel about what like the fact that
like in this in essentially just you've
been reduced to a sexual I don't give a
[ __ ]
you're gonna give a guy 7.5 gallon and
have her come what that's that's the
idol situation for most men like that's
privilege but that is the problem look
at what you've just said and you wonder
why relationships are working the
standard is you someone can call you
even if it's just to help with their
black dick fantasy that's why I don't
have to say the d word sorry black d
fantasy and you're willing to go there I
wonder why it's not the men's fault it's
the women's fault I think the women's
both shares no I don't I don't think so
because like women are in control of sex
but are in control of relationships amen
so yeah so if if they're getting all
these These Hoes like it's their own
fault
there's a guy taking the photos and
calling him in you know
exactly yeah
honestly not not even the boyfriend
because like honestly who's the [ __ ]
that agreed to it it's true like that's
weird is too readily available like look
at what is happening but I just think
unless the birth control pill goes away
I just don't think that's gonna change
I'm still working on abortion laws at
the moment
the people are up in Armstrong abortion
is illegal it's legal in the UK it's
legal in the US it's not legal if you
don't have two doctors sign off on it it
is illegal to terminate a pregnancy okay
but it's still legal for the most like
why do we always look for exceptions
it's not an exception it's not it's free
it's legal it's free it doesn't sign you
can't get an abortion okay do most of
them sign
it's like I forgot I looked at the
number of abortions
yeah it's more like and on top of that
even here in the UK 40 of women that
have had abortions I've had two or more
so is it really that restrictive is it
is it really that hard to get one it's
not to get one but they try to say it's
not legal but you're absolutely why do
you think it's 50 50 though
the responsibility of relationships and
how it's going is is 50 50s like you
said it's both men's and women's fault
because to some degree like men
I feel like there's no Honor on both
sides women aren't honoring themselves
in terms of their body and how sacred it
is to
um have sex with us because we're
receivers whatever energy that man has
you're taking on that's what I think
it's because the sex isn't that valuable
it's really awesome it's been devalued
and in terms of men there's not that
like in my dad's time if you were if you
were having sex with a woman you would
be expected to do The Honorable thing
and make her an honest woman yeah where
is this honest woman she doesn't want to
be honest she wants to be having hot
Ghost Armor with Megan wait wait wait
wait wait wait because throughout time
if you're gonna give a man Pom-Pom he's
gonna take it so you're only an honest
woman if that's the intention from the
beginning but the intention comes from
how you portray yourself but that's what
I'm saying women have not been so free
and open with offering themselves so
what would you say bring back shame and
women then it's not I'm not saying
shaming I'm saying bring back the
sacredness of sex I just don't think you
can unless you get rid of the birth
control pill because that's when you see
marriage yeah that's when you see
marriage rates plummet and so I just
think like she's got a point but you
could say make it sacred but it's not
unless you're a virgin yeah and
everyone's up in women are up in arms
about them possibly making abortions
illegal like so much women are angry
about that well and even with um I
always see girls
um try to like raise their standards and
their value like after they've slept
around right and but it's like you can't
really do that once you've slept around
your low value and it's like and then
you're asking like the next guy to pay
more when you gave it to the last 10 for
free
good point very good point but then
equally as well guys be sleeping around
too it's a small it's a small percentage
of men though and the thing is like do
are women really picking husbands no
they're not they're picking whoever's
gonna understand like I think
yeah
how old are you I'm 33. I got married at
25. yeah that's not normal like in the
UK like the average age of first
marriage is 31. yeah I was married young
as well I was telling her my story of
how I met my husband how I met my
husband and I'd got out of a long-term
relationship and I wasn't willing to
waste time anymore I went on the date
and I took some time to heal I know like
but I took some time out and then I got
on the dating scene but I was very
realistic of what I wanted I was told I
might not be able to have children
um had a lot of miscarriages and I
wanted to make that one of my priorities
I'd had my career are gone to UNI
whatever and I wanted to meet a husband
get well meet someone get married have
kids that was what I had in my mind now
my husband probably thought I was a bit
of a bunny boiler a bit crazy you lot
will probably think I'm a bit crazy but
I went out there dating for the
intention to find that that you know
life goal and I'd go on dates with
people and I'd be like look you know I'm
not saying it has to be now but I'm
saying I'm setting my intentions on what
I want now I want to get married I want
to have kids now most men would probably
think and I've there was lots of men who
were like wow okay okay like this is
first second date whatever but I think
if you're not honest about what you want
and you're not like honest with yourself
you're not honest with the guy then
you're just wasting each other's time
like I think these days people are very
quick to kind of like jump into things
that are you know casual sex or whatever
and if that's what they're looking for
fair play I've got nothing against that
but if you want something more you need
to be like open and honest about that
because other lots of people go into and
I've seen a lot of my friends they say
you know they don't want a long-term
relationship but realistically they do
and that's what they want but they have
pride they have you know they don't want
to be seen as like crazy to put that out
there and and then guys are like you
know then they're getting pregnant like
six months down the line or whatever or
they're or they're you know ex expecting
the guy to be around and and they've not
made their intentions clear from the
beginning so I think it's so important
about you're just wasting each other's
time if you're not on the same page I
you know my hubby was like okay raw this
is a bit march on a second date but he
was like I actually respect the fact
that you're being honest with me and
it's refreshing and I said to them like
you know what there was a lot of dates I
went on and they were like no I'm not on
that page like they're like you're crazy
and I was like ah fair enough see you
later next yeah next isn't it but yeah
at least I got what I wanted and I met
someone who was on the same page as me
and you know and we've got three kids
now we're in a good relationship and
we're both happy
so I love that I think that's that's
really admirable and that is something
that makes a I think you set a precedent
at the start of your relationship and I
remember I went on some dates last year
um
through a couple I went to a couple
girls I met from Bumble and one of them
she said that she would choose the place
we'd go because I was driving to her
yeah and I got she got in my car
and she gave me a post coaching made up
because she hadn't made any plans and
rather than tell me she hadn't made any
plans she gave me a postcode she'd made
up oh man and so I was putting it into
the sat nav and this wasn't coming up
and I was like what this postcode
doesn't exist and then she just made up
some light and about two hours later she
tells me that she hadn't made plans
since she died so and instantly I just
went
how am I ever going to trust this girl
if she's going to lie about something so
basic the very first time I met her and
that was it that there was no chance no
interest in the second day she was a
nice person she was attractive she was a
nice person but she lied to me from like
like she was a friendly personally
driving
around she ain't nice
off the titties I remember the purse it
does not nice but yeah if those if
that's the precedent you're setting at
the start of a relationship run yeah
there's no way that's going to be
healthy whereas what you're saying is
you were basically like honest from the
beginning you were like this is what I
want but I think that you're
what you wanted is something very rare
and the fact that you're willing to
State it is something very rare I think
what happens a lot with women at the
moment I know lots of women because I
used to hang around with a lot of sort
of activisty types lots of feminine
feminists and stuff like that and now
that with all those people I was hanging
around with are hitting their 30s
they're all going why did I spend my
time doing that actually what I want is
a settled relationship I want to have
kids I want to get married and they're
going feminism kind of lie to me about
what I wanted and so that I think that's
more common than what you've done which
is far more adamant and isn't it
feminism in my in its own right because
you're advocating for yourself and your
best self and your happiness self right
your happier self can I ask you
something yeah what how old was you when
you went on this like I'm finding my
husband's Adventure so I was like 24. so
if you look at the way Society is now
what do you think the average 24 year
old oh no they're they're first of all
living their best life
um and I think I think maybe it was my
circumstances of being in a long-term
relationship having a lot of
miscarriages and knowing that I wanted
kids so it set me up for like that was
going to be my priority so I was gonna
ask if that made you like grow up fast
because of that yeah I think I when I
first got pregnant I was you know I've
been with him a while but it wasn't
something that I was planning but then
when I lost the baby it I was like no I
this is what I want like I and it was
you know it became like the at the
Forefront of my mind that I know I
wanted to have and also I didn't ever
have anyone around me that had a happy
relationship I never had I think I had
one friend
um whose parents are still together from
secondary school that had that kind of
good setup but I never went but I knew
that that is what I wanted because I'd
seen so many bad relationships and so
much unhappiness that it kind of made me
go in the opposite direction
I grew up in a a single pep from when I
was four and
um my dad's been about you know he's in
my life he's been in and out of my life
but he's been in my life mostly so I had
him around which I think it can be very
different if you haven't got a father
figure or a mother figure but um but
yeah but I knew what I wanted was the
opposite of what I had as a child and
what qualities did you look for in your
husband that most of your friends like
did not look for in their Partners
obviously there was attraction first
thing because I think that is important
um I met him on
Plenty of Fish Oh serious
that is not a place to meet people I've
done a lot of damage
[Laughter]
[Music]
and it was very different I think to now
oh my God but it was very different I
think to how it is now like I don't envy
people who are going I've got friends
who are still single in their 30s and
the thought of it makes me feel kind of
sick like the just it's very much I
think a sex yes now
um but it wasn't so much then I mean
obviously it was but it wasn't as bad
um but I looked for so first of all
attraction that was you know drew me he
was actually the only guy I ever
contacted because my friend showed me
there was this new like nearby person
like that you could see and then he came
up and I just saw his face and I was
like he's got a nice smile I'm attracted
to Tim and then but what I was looking
for was someone who was kind had the
same values as me had the same goals
um was you know I had something they
wanted to do with their life that was on
the same kind of similar as what I
wanted to do and very family orientated
he's one of nine he's Ghanaian he comes
from a very good he's an African brother
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
don't worry I'm actually a better cook
than him
better than him but but not nice he can
cook he can cook
um but um but yeah I I wanted someone
who came like had a good family kind of
wanted the same things as me see in the
context of the question what this sounds
like to me is that
if we're looking at it from a man and
woman's perspective women tend to be the
problem then because I think the
majority of men are looking for what
your husband currently gives you but
then a lot of women are ignoring that
man because we did say okay what's a
woman that's your age or 24 at the time
doing the girls at festivals and hot
girl summer
what part of that is the man's problem
because that sounds to me like it's the
woman's problem I agreed but it's just
like her I was married young I oh you've
been married yeah I had a child I was
pregnant at 18. my first love stayed
with him married him tried to make it
well because I had this idea of what I
believed a relationship was and when
that didn't work out for me I realized
like you said at the beginning of the
this chat that
I wasn't taught how to vet
so although I embodied the
characteristics of okay I want to be a
wife I want to be a mother family is
important I've left school to do this
like I want this to work I realize I
don't know how to do this what kind of
guy was the guy
to be honest
he was a nice guy
so the relationship was started off
based on a lie so everything I thought I
knew about him was not true but I loved
him through that anyway so he was acting
like he's a legit guy but really he was
Drilling and trapping no he wasn't doing
that he was committed to me but
doesn't mean he wasn't committed that
means he's doing no he wasn't a road man
what what for his circumstances he was
he he didn't he told me the wrong name
he lied about his age and I found out he
did not have um legal status to be in
the UK
okay that's attracted you to this guy he
was kind he was caring he was
considerate he was patient that's a wild
Story how long were you together before
you found this stuff out I was with him
for like a year before I found out all
of this how did you find it out he
confessed when I was eight months
pregnant okay I wanted to say something
but he wasn't he wasn't a bad guy he
wasn't a terrible person I want to say
something I don't I don't agree with the
concept that you have to throw the blame
to the to the women only yeah I think
it's irresponsible for a man to just go
about getting women pregnant or sleeping
around no I I don't want to go with this
sleeping around but I feel it's very
irresponsible it leads to that though no
no no but it's just women women
are women are in control of sex though
men are in control of relationships so
like like it's like yeah Nick Cannon's
irresponsible but who's more
irresponsible the man or the women
opening their legs when he's got seven
baby mamas
yes exactly I agree and so shouldn't we
also Point hands at someone who knows
that he has seven baby mamas and makes
it eight of course yeah but the thing is
right but who's who's in control of
getting pregnant we're in control of
being on birth control we're in control
if you want to be on an IUD you can you
can you can get an abortion too yeah
but these are damaging things to our
body
yeah you know women that are on birth
control are 40 more likely to commit
suicide well check it out
and okay
I understand
I understand like that's like there are
side effects but the point is you only
ovulate a couple days in the month who
knows when you're ovulating we do yeah
and so yeah so we're a hundred percent
in control of birth yes we are and so
that's why it's our responsibility when
we get pregnant
because we're a hundred like no one has
more power in reproduction than us
I I agree with that I agree that a woman
has more power I'm saying that isn't the
man having any responsibility in
ejaculating to a woman I mean yeah he
doesn't have any responsibility
a man doesn't have any responsibility
listen to what I'm saying at the end of
the day think of it if you was a woman
yeah and you know that if you get
pregnant about the the risk of the man
running away is there regardless right
yeah and then at the end of the day if
you get pregnant that's you for nine
months that's your body you mean 18
years
I'm just saying initially when you're
pregnant you're basically out of action
You're vulnerable You're continually
vulnerable
at the end of the day if you know you're
at risk of all those things wouldn't you
take more precautions to protect
yourself yes random guy that you sleep
with I agree with that yeah but no one's
saying that oh it's not a man like as a
man you're an adult you know if you if
you're busting nuts in in girls you need
to understand that she might get
pregnant no one's saying that a guy has
no accountability what was what we're
saying is that in terms of you actually
getting pregnant as a woman you're you
have more power and authority yeah
okay so I I have a question have you
ever been in a toxic relationship yes or
no yeah and if yes what is the most
toxic thing he or she did and what is
the most toxic thing you did
and yeah so yeah so um why don't you
start Eddie
um toxic relationship yeah yeah I've
been the one
was a more toxic thing that I did
nothing it was all her it was mostly her
still I'll be rolly yeah it was mostly
hairstyle nothing it doesn't take too
detangle I'm serious I think probably
the most toxic thing I did was I checked
the phone once
that's probably the most toxic thing
that I did so um I also have a
whiteboard for this part of the okay
where I'm gonna write things on the
Whiteboard and we get to decide as a
group toxic or not toxic
and then and then the most toxic thing
she told me because she told me that
there was like a scale of toxicity of
crazy [ __ ] that she did like cycle [ __ ]
that she did and she was the least
psycho thing she did was that she used
to message me to ask if I was at home
and then she would drive past a window
to check if I was actually in WoW
she used to go up to girls that I knew
and be like just know that
um I know you you're in the same class
as Eddie this is like unique I know
you're in the same class as Eddie just
just went to let you know that I know
that she needs to get an Sia badge
actually
she's wasted
yeah call her but yeah mad oh what am I
going to put on the board so wait what
did you do that was toxic I I should say
I checked the phone okay fine okay
sometimes think toxic I'm in my Rolodex
you said in a relationship in a
relationship
listen speak your mind man if you want
this mic is checking your phone in a
relationship toxic
I wanna do hands so if yes it's toxic
raise your hand
in a phone
okay you're looking for trouble Man
exactly when you when you seek you shall
find in it but the only reason I did it
is because she used to love doing it
yeah
she used to love doing it so one time I
said let me check your phone and she got
bare defensive oh so I was like hmm
Something Fishy here yes and then when I
pre-dip my heart sank bro for real my
immune system shut down I got covered
before even covered happened
what'd you find the maddest Texas
just the whole do you know what most of
all just but you just find bad lies you
just find bad lies saying you're in
certain places when you're not and
you're with certain people and you're
not it was long still
the thing she could tell me the most
sorry the least cycle of things she did
that she could tell me about no is that
she would text me to check whether I was
in and then she would drive past my
window to check if my light was
wondering if I was actually there
[Laughter]
back in the day to do checks
in Tottenham in Cornell College using
like a guy's
to go and check for my friend to see if
he was really there doing his doing was
he
but I helped my friend out we were like
16. I just want to say I don't have the
capacity cheats okay what about you have
you ever been in a toxic relationship
and if so what was the most toxic thing
you both did okay so yeah of course like
because I think everyone said yes
um most toxic thing I probably did in
that relationship
was I mean at that time I was it was
many years ago and I was using a lot of
coke and and different drugs and things
like that and I was basically convincing
her to sell for me which was hey hey
ride or die
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I wasn't
you could say hey hey we could phrase it
the right way helping with a business
yeah that's literally what I was
thinking she's supporting the humanity
made it sound more coercive than it was
like an apprentice when I was out of
town when I was out of town she would do
it for me she was more than willing but
I was still using her for that that's
not toxic that's not toxic I don't think
that's toxic we're gonna raise hands
anyways have you done that yeah it's not
about me
that's called Joint Enterprise
all right having your girls sell drugs
for you raise your hand toxic she agreed
she wanted to make money did she want to
make money and did it all go to her your
girl's a hustler bro
okay actually okay
I don't know we're trying this again
we're trying to look at that in two
years guys we're trying this again raise
your hand if that's toxic
I'm gonna put alive all right I'm a
hustler I'm a hustler homie
I'm gonna say no she's an entrepreneur
[Music]
but the things she did that was toxic
was she she didn't take responsibility
for her emotions but what she would do
is when she would get upset she would do
everything she could to try and make me
lose my temper so she would like shout
and scream at my face and if I went I'm
not having an argument and try and
walked away she would like follow me out
into the street and like grab hold of me
screaming and shouting the road down
trying to make out like do you know you
[ __ ] up bro you meant to choke her and
say bend over I know
yeah troll can say babe shut up and then
give her a little bit of wood I see she
don't say baby I love you
baby I'm sorry I said that
listen for the money no don't
know
I'm not taking your advice
let me let me know how that goes okay
so making him lose his temper yeah I'm
just gonna put talk yeah yeah yeah okay
so so what about you
no bro
come on say with chess
come on
he left he he left to be fair he lied
about his name
I need to think about I'm thinking about
Kobe test
I think my immune system is playing up
foreign
I had the reason to be scared this is
why I'm scared this dude was a whole
different someone with a fake passport
okay okay and a baby and a baby in Ghana
breath so
that was conversation what you still did
was worse
we said you cheated is worse
I don't give a [ __ ]
excuse just because you're young like I
mean you knew what you do like honestly
when you're over like 17 you're doing
16. no it's okay he's a big woman I mean
I I denied it at first
and you lied because he owned up to his
life
I end up eventually
was that by choice
I'm gonna just put toxic
because think about it wasn't just
another guy it was a sugar daddy yeah
man was funding the thing yeah oh so
it's not only getting a Tonton he's
paying for the tunes
honestly I feel like
20s they'll be like oh you're you're
dude at a family across town mine had
three
[ __ ] I didn't
I don't need
to be you're guilty guilty guilty you
know what here hold on I'm gonna put a
red flag
that's something to say
yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna I'm gonna put
it I can't even think of anything now
anyone else we need to slide in the DMS
cancel the mission abort Mission
this was a long time ago yeah
I'm backing you here people I don't
okay 15.
okay okay hold up hold on one second
okay you've got more red flags than a
golf course
[Laughter]
I was in pain I'm gonna draw the ladies
oh
my God why not the men I don't actually
just kept quiet like now I'm like no no
I respect honesty but I'm terrified
husband at 24. you did it properly I
feel bad
I went to I went to therapy for three
years I have to support yeah
oh you went to therapy okay hold on hold
on
oh you're still in therapy hold on
batches okay
have to own up to your [ __ ] like you
can't pretend to be okay I'm not want to
pretend to be okay oh okay I want
Perfection I'm trying to be my best yeah
well can I say what he did to me go
ahead go ahead what did he do what'd he
do
monitoring spirits he those one time
like basically he used to eavesdrop on
my conversations he this is before I
cheated on him right so paranoid about
me yes because some guys when you get
with them The Knife Guy the one that
doesn't get the girls they can't believe
they've got you so they become your
surveillance and this is where he wasn't
my type I said you know what I want the
nice guy but the nice guy couldn't
believe he won oh but see that's what
they say they're dating bad boys I had
daddy issues so he was the guy he was
the guy that was quiet he was respectful
he was kind he was calm but he couldn't
believe in himself that he actually got
me but then he started being extra with
monitoring my phone checking my phone to
the point where I went out one time to
use the pay phone to have a private
conversation with my girlfriend and I
turned around and this dude is standing
by the glass family I was like no did
that breathing on the window
but this is where they say you can't
this is why they say you can't date a
girl after she's dated bad guys because
she'll cheat on the nice guy with the
bad boys
yeah I mean it doesn't it doesn't matter
I agree it doesn't matter what he was
doing like he lied about his whole life
I mean I understand then leave but if
you choose to cheat your cheater I mean
yeah it's like I didn't understand like
I'm not saying you enjoyed it I'm not
I'm not saying you will be forever but
like there's you can't not take
accountability and say I was young she
cheated and she enjoyed it
okay wait wait hold on hold on do you
know what Paul you need to invest in
like a red flag hat so you can just wear
it the red flag hat on us hold hold on
to that one still hurt people hurt
people but I don't agree
again after dating a bad boy Will Smith
is a perfect example eight years on and
off and um this was my toxic
relationship before and it made me
realize that I didn't want that life I
didn't want it and I went to therapy I
worked on myself I worked on my issues
and I went for a good guy and I have not
cheated on him I will not cheat on him
and we are happy so I don't think that
I'm not I'm not so I'm not hold on I'm
not saying that you can't date after but
I'm saying from a man's point of view if
you could pick a girl that hasn't had a
toxic ax or you pick a girl that has a
toxic ax why why wouldn't you pick the
one that has it yeah he'd probably say
like I had issues a bit when I went yeah
yeah because it comes with problems and
it's not it's not saying like no girls
can come back from it ever some some do
but a lot of them will cheat because
they're not really attracted to the nice
guy I have seven red flags can we take
some off no no no
it doesn't matter I mean
[Music]
you heard more than that so she took
outside
I mean oh it's 15 years ago so yeah okay
what do we
okay okay let's let's ask the she's
let's she's very nice you're about to
talk
um everyone but the ladies how many red
flags should she have 10.
we need red flag much
so far
we haven't seen there yeah
should we okay okay you know what you
know what should I give Eddie a red flag
yes
I need you to rationalize logically the
red flag that I've acquired okay
rationalize it for me all right all
right to be friends why it's toxic okay
is that
in that situation where you were in an
unknown place okay
and the guy was sitting down you don't
know his intentions in fact you put
yourself in that situation and you did a
good job on the woman yeah which which
could kind of cause a repercussion in
which the guy could have become violent
in that situation
my point was uh talks is because
there is an element of an unknown that
could result in violence yeah that's
true but there's also element of unknown
that makes it exciting but wait
more than Uber you see my chest brother
you think a man's gonna come and try to
punch me up if you got to evaluate the
situation prior listen man I'm from the
streets bro when you walk in an
environment you need to know where I go
on what no I mean I mean yeah yeah
okay now now that we've had the
discourse
raise your hand if you think Eddie
deserves a red flag just the three guys
I know we're not we're gonna take the
man's opinion so so you think red flags
no no no okay you need no red flag I
ain't toxic self-awareness with the wavy
not them too yeah
but he had he had to do this so he's
innocent I wasn't I was an object
Michael your turn that's
right I forgot sorry your turn I can't
the only thing I can think of is we went
back and forth to each other so many so
many times and that was toxic in itself
we didn't know how to separate eight
years of back and forth back and forth
when the relationship was dead from
three years in so fair enough so that
was toxic but I feel like I'm just gonna
put toxic we can yeah breaking up and
getting back together right raise your
hand toxic yes breaking up all the time
and getting back together
no I hear that yeah it's toxic yeah it's
toxic but so what there was an
individual characteristics that you both
did that were toxic within the
relationship arguing
with me that one one girl that I knew
she was talking she used to cry a lot so
she would cry and that would make me
feel bad they're not large you know what
I'll give you a blind so did you do
anything like that like you manipulate
him through your tears or
laughs
I think he was trying to do
I I think I took him away from what he
was trying to do he was trying to be a
music producer like most guys are back
in the day you know get a real job
and I was trying to take him away to
kind of focus on having a kid and all
that so I was taking him away from where
he wanted to go to be fair my sister
told me he's actually a really famous
YouTuber now we're not going to go there
but he's done well for himself so I
think uh breaking up was the best thing
that we could have done because he got
what he wanted I got what I wanted
enough from different people I think
you're removing a man from his mission
is toxic yeah that is yeah I mean I
didn't do it in the sense of you have to
choose but well you came first
[Music]
he was on a mission to have a baby and I
even though he was on the same path as
me he really if I'd listened to him
truly that's not what he wanted he
wanted to focus on him and his music
career and I and I was still trying to
kind of I wanted him to do that but I
also wanted the other stuff do you see
how could I that could have gone wrong
though in the sense that if he let's say
you got pregnant and he wasn't really in
it and he left now society would say it
was his fault but you kind of pushed it
on him
know and and I realized that and I
realized that I had to get out of that
and that it wasn't going to make us both
happy and I didn't want to be a single
mom so but at the time I mean I was with
him from when I was 17. it was toxic it
was and and I look back now and I think
I should just said you know what you do
your thing you focus on your music and
you know we'll wait but I obviously had
all the medical stuff going on so I was
like but I'm going to come to your
defense a little bit did you coerce him
into that or was he making a choice and
you were saying this is what I want and
he was not stating what he wanted and
just going along with you no he was
stating what he wanted but I was stating
what I wanted as well and he was like
okay kind of yeah so no one was
confident he wasn't strapping up
on the pill and he knew I wanted a baby
so you're nice
I still have seven Flags
maybe throughout the show I'll take one
off we'll see we'll see
Michael your turn all right so um my
toxic relationship uh the girl she was
kind of like knocking me off for my
purpose and um she used to cry on the
phone like she's very emotional and
stuff like that so like oh yeah come see
me and I'm like I've got things to do
and she's all crying and you know it
would make me feel bad and stuff like
that so eventually because of the
arguments and everything we broke up
well I broke up with her but then I kept
smashing her in it that toxic really
yeah
obviously like she wanted me back but it
was just like it was never gonna work
but I'm attracted to her like you know
what I'm saying I like the beat so
obviously I was going back and beating
her and saying nice things like yeah
maybe we might you're doing the yo-yo
thing you're doing the yo-yo thing so
you're like I'm gonna fling your back
but I'm gonna give you some Willy and
bring you back in yeah yeah yeah all of
that so like that was pretty toxic but
that wasn't the most toxic thing I did
though [ __ ] oh God in my life like it
wasn't to her most toxic thing I had a
girlfriend and I slept with two other
girls from POF
bruh in the same day
like same day and then my girl at the
time she wanted to come see me after but
then I was feeling a little bit guilty
so I was like now I'll see you tomorrow
all tired
she didn't find out nor did he insert
himself inner to disrespect her from
those interactions I don't think it's
toxic but she don't know she didn't know
so she still thought she was in a
relationship with you sorry and you're
on POF it is yeah yeah it's cheating but
it's not toxic she got red flags it is
cheating but yeah okay giving a flag for
cheating it's not talking yeah it's one
at a time one at a time she got red
flags for cheating with one person
if you're gonna say cheating cool fact
but it's not toxic well men and women
cheating isn't the same
yeah it's not the same I'm not I still
I'm still giving you red flag Michael
I'm sorry
but yeah because you would have you had
a kid so you're cheap you're cheap
you're seven yeah but you're cheating as
a mother he's just cheating as like okay
you're kind of single until you're
married to be honest I wasn't married
then though she wasn't married do you
have a kid I had a kid I mean your
mother
quotes
So you married him after all this yes
[Laughter]
to the sugar
Daddy no he's the resources no that
actually make even worse like he wasn't
even attracted to him you just slept
with him just for the piece he wasn't
ugly
so you basically wait wait wait wait
wait so you basically were a hooker
escort
that's good I genuine enjoyed hanging
out with us but you also got money you
paid for your services
he
yeah because of all the things
he has a good personality listen okay
it actually is
hiding him behind my oh God it's getting
worse another flag
[Laughter]
please
this girl's doing this and they're
paying for me Michael now tell me the
most crazy thing that she did that she
did uh well actually recently she's been
calling me from private number she
called me 21 times it is recently yeah
I have a question when's the last time
you slept with her
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so does how many red flags
does Michael get right now right now
he's at five
going back and forth I think it's toxic
I think it is how many how many flags
does he get well so I gave him I gave
him five for them
wow
yeah you're another okay so are you
leading her on completely does she think
oh she comes to me she calls me like and
she knows that there's no chance of
getting back together yeah I think she's
trying to get pregnant for me don't do
it bro
[Music]
I can't have a red flag give out red
flags I need the green flag
so he's got them for the cheating so
this is just for yeah yeah now he's at
five for the the two girls I mean like
one girl one girl
no but wait wait wait let's see
that girl this one that you're seeing
now I'm just saying it don't say that
would die 21 times yesterday
last time
that was about like four months ago
but it's only toxic if he gets caught
why is it toxic in a relationship
because the girls don't know about it
because she's not my girl
to be fair she's not his girl you're
saying she's selling herself a dream
you're saying that she knows fully that
where she stands I broke up with her yes
we're not together another way that
you're getting back together she knows
that she left the country because of the
situation to go and get a man rat came
back
I don't know why maybe you made a girl
leave the country you've got a toxic
shlong hit me
in the country no one left the country
there might be a few red flags okay so
you you can have the final I'm gonna
give you
three I'm being kind yeah three yeah and
I have
I have no that's it you can't say
nothing you you said you wanted this
number in the beginning of the show so
this is like the red this is the red
flag relationship
you guys can like you guys can be like
the toxic she saw the gold
it's a live date here right now you know
what's your sign oh here we go
[Laughter]
some some people find love on this show
I don't know I don't know trust me I
know I get bad DMS asking about girls
after the show
have you been in a toxic relationship
um
that means yes when you have to say um
I won't really say toxic toxic it was
just more of a narcissism that was just
basically where
um she felt that
what I tell her that she's doing wrong
isn't wrong so yeah so that's totally
and she comes up with ways to defend her
actions and so no account manipulation
manipulation yeah that's quite that's
probably bad because it's like it's
always your fault right yeah yeah and
then when they say something it's like
oh you're being crazy you're being crazy
not really like that she just comes up
with ways in which
um maybe it's something something is
happening and I'm saying that I know you
shouldn't do that and she's like you
know it's a good idea to do this and she
comes up with ways to say that that idea
is not bad
so manipulating we're going to say toxic
yeah yeah okay so anyways the winner of
the red flag contest
how do you feel I feel good you feel
toxic because I was in so much pain back
then so I'm so proud of the woman I am
today oh my God no I am I'm proud of who
I am today how much girls would have
come on here and admitted that they
would have lied to me like oh I I don't
know nothing you know you know there's
women out here watching me who have had
seven abortions you have a cemetery for
a stomach do not judge me yeah
you know you know what's interesting
though you know what's interesting and I
can just kind of see the men versus
women dynamic because like like you when
um she was talking were defending her
but when Michael was talking you're like
oh that's kind of bad but even though
yeah
no even if she's making bad decisions
you don't know her 21 like dude was a
whole different person like a few months
ago I just like I mean I've had 20 I've
been 21 before but like I can't imagine
ever like sleeping with a sugar daddy
but you're married like when you would
have a child I wasn't married to him
though yeah but like I just think that's
why you get the you have a baby isn't
that worse like a baby mom I like it was
technically he was someone else that
wasn't the person outside the
relationship let's see okay I'm gonna
give you another red flag because
the thing is like like it's one thing to
say okay I did that it was [ __ ] up and
I shouldn't have did it no right but
when you're you're like saying oh well I
was young like it's like it's like when
you say I'm sorry but it's like when you
give an excuse it kind of It kind of
takes away the accountability going
through a lot so okay it was wrong you
know what though I do appreciate honesty
because it does take a lot to admit
something like that it don't mean you're
gonna get a black friend should we
should we take away red flag for honesty
I have never done any female
because you've said a lot of Madness
with a sugar daddy and a child
just accept it it's okay I wasn't
married to him it's okay I was he's not
he was not my husband you've also got to
remember you only had like three or four
red flags from the incident and then
everything you said after is what got
you the rest of them no I think it's
just super judgment going on because I
told you what I did oh of course there's
judgment going on I said what I did so
why are we getting extra Flags I've told
you what I did yeah but you're defending
yeah
I'm making assumptions based on the
information you gave me yeah I cheated
on him that is the information and I I
did the same thing to Michael he got red
flags too if you know if I just kept
quiet
[Laughter]
thank you
like I'm not sorry
you need to get red flag merch like a
red flag hat or like a big red t-shirt
and you're gonna wear that for the rest
of the show just so you know to stay
away a lot of people are doing stuffers
and they're lying about it
is away on work and they are sleeping
around oh yeah I don't know men that are
doing the same
thing I don't think
um yeah but how is it better how is it
better just because you were married you
had a kid so you may as well be married
that's it okay
honestly that's a bigger commitment
I could I could get married to a guy
tomorrow yeah and then be divorced never
talk to him again if he's a kid with
someone you're stuck with them for Life
True yeah so he was not my husband I did
not vow to commit my life to him
we were on and off yeah
that point I didn't value the
relationship the wealth being treated
yeah you should have stepped yeah but
why is there always an excuse like this
is this is the thing but this thing's
led to that it's not it's not good that
I did it it's not good but it's the only
thing I'm pointing out is like this is
the difference between men versus women
is women are allowed to make excuses for
their bad behavior that was terrible no
no no and you keep arguing with it
because because when you're when Michael
when Michael was judged in the same room
with you the same thing happened to him
we we judged Michael Ten red flags and
and and and and and and Michael just
took it but you're like arguing with it
I am arguing with it when you're saying
like like but it's like it's the same
behavior it was bad it was bad it's true
it's true it didn't make anything thank
you appreciate it I appreciate you I
appreciate the skills
that some men do make it pieces as well
but you didn't he did it no I think I
think some men do but in general most
don't and I do I know this because I I
talk to people four days a week and even
on even on even on Tick Tock when um I
talk about men versus women cheating
whenever it's about a woman cheating
it's always well why did she cheat yeah
but it doesn't it doesn't because it
because it's worse how because men are
men are supposed to protect and provide
women but women okay I don't know your
situation but I'm talking about cheating
and you're changing the subject and you
ask you you stopping her up to stop
interrupting me when we're talking about
cheating okay that's what we're talking
about men's duty is to protect and
provide women are supposed to be loyal
and so and so if you're not loyal that's
you're going against what you're
supposed to do I was loyal but I wasn't
faithful
it's not it's not it's not it's not
loyal but the difference between loyalty
and faithful no it's not loyal you
weren't loyal like think about this
loyalty okay okay I can't I'm just
thinking I'm just thinking about this
for my mom and dad and I'm thinking if
my mother like said to me oh I was
faithful all right I was loyal I wasn't
faithful I'm like I'm like what are you
talking about like is that what you
teach your daughter is the difference
between being loyal and being faithful
okay tell me the difference between
being loyalist you are there no matter
what throughout which I was until the
relationship ended but in being faithful
I wasn't being true that is the
difference I I think you're just making
up words
same thing if loyalty and faithfulness
are the same thing why are they two
different things
for women loyalty for women for women
for women women loyalty is being
sexually exclusive because historically
men had to ensure paternity for men
loyalty is giving us their resources and
so that's why you got more red flags
than Michael did for cheating because
you're not doing what a woman's supposed
to do
I do think with him knowing that's me
like 15
with him knowing he would call you loyal
yes
no I know what I did for him and he
knows what I did for him so he held the
strap
oh he was a good guy actually so you
wouldn't have done that yeah no I I I
held it down for him yeah yes I'm saying
that with my whole chest I'm
to it and you enjoyed it
it's real foreign
no women women tend to find Jesus when
they need a husband and time's running
out
I didn't want to get married when I
found it
I'm glad I did because it made me
realize how messed up a lot of the
decisions I was making do you think the
church keeps the women single
just yes to some degree and then to some
degree no why well I asked a man
recently why is it there's more women in
church than men and he said
um if men see BS and spot it they're not
gonna stick around whereas women will be
led they'll be convinced but um I think
if I think to be honest Church there's a
lot of feminism seeping into the church
and we're not aware of it like we're
like we like you said women do blindly
support each other
we do though we do though I can admit
that yeah we do blindly support each
other and sometimes me too you need to
just be like sis you're moving mad you
need to cut that out yeah and I think if
we don't have that
like women don't like to be corrected
like I was arguing just a minute ago
more than once it was messed up modern
women don't want to admit that and even
like especially becoming a Christian
actually taking it seriously I realized
so much of the things I was doing was
just me be acting out of pain and not
wanting to take accountability like I do
think so to me like I think a lot of the
problem in the church is they always
give women excuses and bailouts
and so you can say I would like and I
hate doing this but this is like a
perfect example because what they'll do
is they'll like victimize women and
they'll say oh I was so broken I was in
such a bad headspace I was so this I
didn't have Jesus
and then like they can come back and say
oh I got baptized and now I'm a good
woman and it's like but to be honest
with you in in when I first gave my life
to Christ
I was like that yeah but the more I
pressed into actually reading the Bible
and actually allowing the Holy Spirit to
work on me I realized there's so much
things that had to come out well and and
it may be genuine for you but it's not
the same person anymore this like for me
now I don't have sex because at the end
of the day my main thing is I did not
want to agree with the Holy Spirit if
you're having sex outside of marriage
God created marriage for a safe space
for women to have sex and pleasure he
does want you how many how many kids do
you have I have one we have one yeah do
you think that keeps you single though
because why would a guy wait to marry
you if you he you gave someone else a
kid well the man that God has for me
will wait no but that's the thing no no
he won't because then I guess if I'm if
I die single I'll rather die single and
please the Lord to go and sleep around
in the hopes of maybe getting a man but
but the thing is that the Bible also
says to be fruitful and multiply yes
within the context and sanctity of
marriage which may be true but I look at
results and that's the thing like like
when I go into any church I just see
this plethora of single women yes there
is and it's like if if you're selling a
used car for new prices who's gonna buy
it where do you but then I wouldn't want
a man like I'm happy to be with a man
that is has a previous children from a
previous relationship I'm not gonna say
oh he needs to be right he used to have
eight figures he needs to be single he
can't have kids I'm not doing that I
know that okay I've got a child my
bargaining power is less than right but
the thing is it would be it would be a
good deal for you because when a guy has
kids it's a sign of pre-selection that
he can take care of them so that's
that's the thing that like I see in
churches is they they tell men to accept
bad deals because it would be a good
deal for you would be a bad deal for him
well if he has kids yeah even so but he
can take care of those kids I'm taking
care of mine right right but like men
don't care about your money like our
bargaining power is different it's
Purity and youth where you get
protection and provisioning so you get
you get the benefits and he doesn't but
if you have the trump card of um being
cooperative being submissive that could
work I'm saying it's a good character
you're you're correct and it can but
what I'm saying is one there aren't
enough men in the church to even for
everyone to get married and the other
issue is that you're again you're
selling a used car for new prices when
if you you know when really you're on
sale but and you should be and you might
have bet like and I would think people
in the church like a lot of like the
single mothers I see in the church would
have better outcomes if they just put
themselves on sale because they also say
to be submissive yeah and being
submissive isn't oh you have to wait to
marry me to have sex but because that's
on your rules
though yes trust me stop it
I've been quoted by a man in church and
he didn't attempt to have sex with me
because he understood that and he was
single he didn't have a child you're
more likely to meet a man
he was willing to do the journey with me
because he took his faith seriously why
didn't you marry him because he wasn't
the right one for me no because you
weren't attracted to him because he's a
Sam no we no
because because that's not that's synth
Behavior that's it like honestly because
if you if you had a son that was
childless you wouldn't want him to date
a single mother that's a born-again
virgin and you might not say born again
virgin but you may as well be yeah but
can I just say I actually know and a
couple who met in church I'm going to
give you some hope here and they both
had children and they have both they're
they married and they're having they're
expecting that but possibility of
possibility possibility or women women
like thinking possibilities instead of
probabilities when the majority of the
women I see in the church are single so
you can say oh here's this fairy tale
that might happen to you to you but if
you keep selling a used car at new
prices that like the majority of women
will end up single and that's what
you're seeing in the churches walk into
any church the majority of the women are
single they think I've got Jesus I'm
okay
and they think that but the problem is a
lot of women will be homeless even in
the UK you guys have a lot of bailout
programs but let's say let's say they
can't afford those anymore where will
you go do you have 2.5 million for
retirement you'll be on the streets and
so finding a relationship can be life or
death for a lot of women because he's
more vulnerable than women on the tree
so you can like you can say oh it's nice
and like like here here's this fairy
tale that could happen for you and I
think it's because like you're very
sweet but the probability is a lot
longer yeah can I can I also say that
there's a lot of working parts to
um being a single Christian woman
because one of the reasons as well if
especially for those of you that are not
spiritual
I dreamed that this man was not the man
for me I asked God is this the man and
eventually after a couple of weeks of
dating the guy God spoke to me Jim said
he's not the guy yeah so at the end of
the day for me whoever I marry now
there's no divorce we are dying together
so I want to do it the right way okay at
the same time a lot of women do I agree
with you they do use Jesus as a crutch
without doing the inner self work it's
you you will stay single if you do not
do the you know I just think to a guy
this sounds like nonsense but like this
sound this sounds so good because
because it sounds like nonsense to me
but and I'm not spiritual there's things
that you if you're not using your
spiritual eyes to see certain things no
no no don't don't do that don't do that
I spent I spent 12 years in Catholic
school I grew up in a Catholic face I
actually wanted to be a virgin till I
was married and I and I waited a long
time and and like didn't get they didn't
do any of that so you can't say oh it's
like a spiritual thing you don't feel
spiritually but I'm saying I'm saying
you can say it like inner work like
whatever but like I'm talking about
results but I'm talking about a
spirit-led life not going to church
church going to church you're not being
mocked on your attendance your God
weighs your heart so you could be going
to church there's people that never miss
a Sunday but their heart is black and I
I understand I understand that like but
what I'm saying is like the world
doesn't owe you understanding that's
fine and that's fine but I'm saying like
if if you don't have 2.5 million to
retire there's a chance you could be
homeless if you don't figure out how to
get along with a dude and it's going to
be hard to do that if you're selling a
used car for new prices fair enough but
I'm also so in business myself I'm I
provide for myself I'm not um quick
question please what was the reason for
single ladies being in church what was
there does anyone know the main reason I
mean I I I think that like the church
has driven out men because one they tell
them to accept bad deals too they
thought they'd go to church and find a
wife and they find the girls are
freakier in the church than out of the
church
and three like feminism has infiltrated
a lot of and and feminine and guys guys
one at a time and feminism has
infiltrated a lot of the churches and so
it's like they don't really stand for
anything anymore I see I see that I mean
I don't know if this drives out men in
particular but I see I see gay flags
outside of churches not my church
okay so what on the other side what do
you think are the reasons why we don't
have men in church I think I think I
think the church has driven out men
because feminism has infiltrated the
church agreed and so I think they've
taken power away from Men in the church
and they've given it to the women yes we
call that the Jezebel spirit the church
has basically abandoned all of the
narratives that attracted men to it in
the first place you know they don't they
don't emphasize the need to take
responsibility into the you know the
bear your cross narrative that they used
to and I I was raised atheist
um I would now describe myself as
religiously confused
but I I recently attended church a few
months ago thinking you know this is
something I'm interested in I've been
developing a sort of spiritual practice
and I went there looking for that
narrative you know in in the style of
Jordan Peterson who who picks apart the
biblical stories and explains what they
mean the significance they have to you
as a person and how you can improve
yourself as a person using the biblical
stories and I went there and I found it
really wishy-washy and uninteresting
and slightly woke as well
um you know like in the middle of the
sermon the Reverend started going on
some tangent about Asylum Seekers and
refugees and need to welcome them all in
and things like that and although I
think that's a separate conversation to
the church and that's not what the the
whole point of the religious Endeavor is
it is supposed to be about introspection
and making yourself a better person not
about this social justice thing that
they seem to have picked up and so I
think that's why a lot of men are
leaving the church or even even like Roe
versus Wade in the US that should be a
win for churches it is like that yeah it
should be but it's not like even even
the church I was involved in in the US
they can't come forward and say that's a
win
exactly so secularism has infiltrated
the church yeah there's not that I agree
I think um
Jesus that guy on the cross like this
yeah kinky you know he's been a
feminized they've a feminized God and at
the end of the day I agree with what you
said if you actually look at the
accounts of the Bible men were men women
women were led by men there was of men
had Authority and I think you are
absolutely right feminism has
infiltrated the church and that male
Authority is not encouraged or
celebrated even in society as a whole
masculinity is frowned upon you're
called toxic quickly nowadays A man
can't even say oh hey babes you look
good can I get a number because even on
the train now like don't get me wrong
some things aren't necessary like
touching without consent is
inappropriate but generally a man is not
encouraged to be an alpha male or I know
that word's thrown around but I mean
someone that is aggressive not in a
negative way but you know actively
masculine that is frowned upon yeah well
and I also think
I think they encouraged Behavior they
tell you to wait for a born-again virgin
and they I don't know why they would
tell girls to wait but the man also is
told to wait as well yeah but you know
it's different it's like a bad deal for
him because he still has to protect and
provide but he doesn't get Purity or
youths so yeah so before she went to the
church it's like it's like okay
yeah but but it's not but men and women
but okay okay I'll give you an example
but men and women aren't the same so I
went to Carnival and I interviewed men
yeah I said what would you rather pick
would you rather have a girl that had
fifty thousand dollars worth of credit
card debt you have to pay off or 50
bodies and I asked the same question to
men into women and the women said you
know I can deal with the bodies I'm not
taking the debt and the guy said I will
pay off fifty thousand dollars in debt
before I had before I take a girl with
50 bodies and and so it's like men and
women don't value Purity at the same
rate meant that that's like one of the
most important things to them they don't
want to be with a girl that has done
embarrassing [ __ ] in the past that's
embarrassing to them where women don't
we don't really care it's kind of a flat
account or the debt
that's the thing like like that's to us
it's kind of a flex because he slept
with all these girls and he he locked
you down so it's a bit of a whoever lost
yeah so if whoever the girl is I mean
he'd probably be in the streets forever
but like if someone if someone if
someone locked down Drake let's say yeah
that would be a flex because he could
pick anyone he picked you it would
celebrate that girl yeah and for a woman
like Brittany Renner do you guys want to
be with Brittany Runner Brittany
Brittany Renner is the she's been with
like every athlete like oh yeah yeah is
it is it would it be a flex to have
Brittany runner on your arm I'll chop
her up but I wouldn't I wouldn't
mind oh yeah
just make up on my resume and so by
encouraging men to do that you're saying
take a bad deal be a cent but then
equally is in terms of women if the man
has like again I'll say again if the man
has children from previous relationships
it doesn't matter they're both not
having sex with each other you're both
waiting it's not like you're one
sleeping around while the others waiting
like anything
I just think that the woman would have a
hard time respecting the man because one
you know damn well you don't deserve
that like you don't you don't deserve to
be waited for if you if you you're not a
virgin but you're waiting on him too
but if she's a virgin it's different if
she's a virgin yeah because he gets the
Purity and the youth but if he doesn't
get the Purity in the youth it's a bad
deal for him but if she's still young
okay she's not pure he's still young
he's not pure either but they're both
agree so you're you're it's not going to
be you're you're equating that that that
sleeping round is the same for men and
the women
okay but so why are you using that
argument because it's not because in in
a spirit-led church when you decide to
do this you're both not having sex it's
not like one is keeping yourself and the
other's going out or whatever right
we're both waiting on each other right I
understand you're both waiting for each
other I I I I understand that but the
point is we're talking about the deal
that they get the sexual Market
I'm saying they are paying new prices
for a used car you get a good car at
good prices
so why is he a good call why is he a
good car because other women liked that
car
they picked that car and now you're
buying it from the previous box my
question is I know a lot of people that
have like you know I talk about health I
do women's womb health and I always end
up talking about health stuff and people
have opened up to me
and admitted that they have herpes
there's a lot of people that have herpes
and what is that after okay what is that
what is that what does that have to do
with it okay let me land the reason why
I'm saying that is people are coming
with their baggages whether that be baby
mothers that there's hardly any resolve
with
whether that be like as you said for the
women you're a used car and now you're
you're saying you're not having sex
everyone's got their own deal I
understand that's all I'm saying I I
agree with you women have a less
bargaining power I agree right but the
but the church acts like they have the
most bargaining power like they they
kind of put women on a pedestal in the
church
I agree with you like you need to raise
your standards it's like no they need to
raid their raise their standards so the
men need to write yeah the man because
they keep they keep accepting bad deals
but not necessarily in church most of
the time when people go for each other
it's it's rare that you'll find a single
young man going for a woman that has one
or two kids even they tend to even cross
even I agree I do think like ideally
people with kids should date each other
but even the dude with kids waiting for
a girl that's not a virgin is sent
behavior and and you know I've explained
it in one differently what is he waiting
for that's what I don't know that's what
I'm confused but they're both not having
sex
from from a guy's perspective I feel
like you're speaking for a man in this
in the situation like what am I waiting
for whether or not I'm I'm having sex or
whatnot what am I gaining from you when
it's already been had by next month
you're not it's not again in that
respect okay they've gain because I've
asked people that have done this and
have ended up in marriage what they are
saying what they have told me is they
are waiting because yes they've they've
done whatever in the past but because
they've become Christians they
understand that and God does not like
promiscuity he frowns upon marriage um
slamming you up I ain't waiting
but this is why the men are leaving
[ __ ] for them and you can find a couple
simps that'll figure it out and have
their fairy tale but they're Sims and
everyone in the room knows their samps
and even the girls know their Sims and
that's why I see all these couples in
the church where the woman's like
grabbing her like she she wears the
pants in her relationship even Church
even Church relationships they don't
even look submissive half the time
exactly like the girls lead feminism has
taken over right but I'm saying part of
that is encouraging men to accept bad
deals can I agree to some extent can I
ask something this confuses me a little
bit because I understand where it comes
from but
does it not scare you to buy before
you've tried and and because of the four
likes yes it does of marrying someone
and then the the sex is [ __ ] yes
why is it [ __ ] I have a story why is it
the sexiest [ __ ] because you have too
much experience that's the whole point
so if you had slept with less people how
could the sex be [ __ ] because what are
you comparing it to
um I can I interject there if that's
true but I I don't know like some people
I think connect sexually and some people
might not no no no no no no no no
she waited and when she finally had sex
with the like when she got married him
my man was working with two inches sis
was pissed she was pissed they did the
whole no one's having sex with no one
the guy
she was like no deal I'm not gonna lie
to you she she cut that off was she was
she I have a question was she a virgin
she wasn't a virgin yeah
that's the point that's the that's the
point Eddie was making so like a
virgin's not gonna know yeah they're not
gonna because she's not like but like as
someone you you it's true yeah as
someone who's had and that's and that's
why again because now as a non-virgin
you have to worry about sexual
incompatibility and so be agreed and so
that's that's another reason why it like
guys that do that are Sims
because like they they have to worry
about like you could you could wait you
could find a guy he waits till he's
married and then you guys have zero
bedroom chemistry because you've been
slinging it out yeah
most of them guys yeah that are doing
all that waiting those are not the guys
you really want bro that's not the guy
that you're really really attracted to
the guy who's really attractive not you
yeah but a guy that he was really
attracted to you slept with him like um
a year ago man see imagine imagine wife
imagine wife and a girl that Mike would
slept with previously game over uh
[Laughter]
long yeah I just wanted to bring in
another video
and that's the very way of location
um there are some parts of the United
States where I think this is your theory
of the church is going to apply and
there are some parts of the US that it
won't apply in which you have more male
dominance especially in the Mid-South
Midwest and Mid West towards the South
you have a strong male dominance you
have a strong Christian values you have
a strong traditional value values in the
church so um I just wanted to bring that
in that I think we should not just
generalize that oh churches do this yeah
right I mean I I think anyone like we
know there's exceptions there's good
churches but like I think there's
General problems when the churches when
you continue to go into them and there's
a bunch of single mothers and single
people agreed and I and I've done all of
them I've done I've Christian Catholic
like I've been to a lot of different
churches
in different countries too same problems
going back to the thing you were saying
about everyone has baggage though the
sort of point is that people value
different baggage differently
and once you're a parent your kid should
be your priorities
but there's different risk levels and if
uh if you bring a step parent in they're
16 times more likely to abuse the child
that's true and men are more likely to
abuse than women in that situation as a
step parent
therefore yeah it does a male has a
child already he's not taking as much
risk when he's bringing a woman in fact
so so him having a child isn't the same
baggage as you having a child agreed
with that said though then but with that
said then a woman should be even more
considerate with the person who's having
a childhood because then you're you're
not thinking about the child in a
situation where you have a kid in and
break up because you put your kid in
that risk yeah yeah yeah 100 I agree I
agree with you the point I was making is
a guy having a child isn't the same and
remember the baggage because he has he
hasn't got to consider that risk to the
same degree to protect his child yeah
he's the protector of that yeah and also
most of the time they're living with the
mum more than the dad so it's it's
vulnerable um
I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats okay so I don't I don't like them
okay Adam Adam Sutton um please explain
to sexy church lady the weight of a man
is being a stepdad wizard ape God says
women can have multiple wives God says
women can have multiple wives and that
loves a choice Church says one man to
one woman for control wizard ape the
chick the chick with herpes really
thinks she's doing something Obi Obi
wait till I'm done with the super chats
wait till I'm done then you can speak
your piece um you can tell a tree by its
fruits the only fruit that is being
displayed is the
um
wait the only fruits that is being
displayed is a low quality woman The
Need to Be Right the right here is not
submissive the UK Economist this will
settle the debate please ask if your
guests if they would want their daughter
to wait until marriage or have multiple
bodies Christian sirdak Pearl you may
you may as well talk to a houseplant she
will continue her mental and verbal
gymnastics right into her grave zero
accountability brilliant Magnum
um to my brother on the sofa here's a
quick fix for your confusion read the
Quran Ian Mack this is a reoccurring
line here are you saying if a woman has
if a woman has a single one night stand
she then has to give it up on the first
night every time after wizard ape toxic
toxic takes away accountability you can
walk away from a person you can control
your own feelings toxic is a
self-identified term based on no set
point feminists or being Insidious Matt
butcher one piece skin suit plant your
red flag on the hill and die there with
your cats great learning here Pearl
Robert ever new here do you read super
chats Pearl drazian gaming how is the
Jaylee Warden a repeat offender Stefan
sinless I'm Progressive and love your
content saying lefties no um lower
infant mortality rates leads to less
genetic health problems in a population
a third of men's genes are bad same for
girls but for men or less picky
industrial food and medicine has doomed
us all Mark our Mar asks who is
considered a leftover woman age group
Ava rosu pushing young marriage is not
enough time to be a 304 married at 19
only been with him women you're jealous
now now that I'm 30 they made fun of me
in our 20s Gus women set the market
value and men just adapted kilton
Daniels membership Ship has its
privileges puffy Vegas the woman in Gray
is average wizard ape just stopping in
Pearl you're a leader and inspire me to
be which I'm done wait till I'm done
Pearl you're a leader and inspire me to
be a better man thank you for helping me
with my own personal rest recipe I hope
being I hope the good men are blowing
you up this old lady even old ladies
support just pearly things ladies submit
with Grace and gratitude and you will
forever have cover I'll leave that Pearl
here
um Gus if ladies knew that they lose 80
percent of their eggs by 30 and 90 to 95
by 35 why are women waiting to get
married and have kids Colin Dublin for
modern women peace is scarier than
dysfunction if it ain't dysfunctional it
ain't normal so they reject it mgtow by
Logic marriages last about five years
plus one to two for divorce processes
because that's about as long as women
can live the LIE of marrying a man they
don't want to be want to begin with and
to be with to begin with it's her
relieving her psychological torture and
because F him
um High Plains Drifter hello from
America it's our desire
that the whole world chooses Liberty we
are all created equal equal govern your
own life according to the natural law
treat others how you want to be treated
Liberty is the only way hashtag Liberty
mgtow by Logic No leftover women don't
know what a good relationship is
otherwise they wouldn't be left over
obviously
okay so then let me refresh it real
quick also guys like the video that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out this content so make
sure you like the video also let me know
in the chat how many red flags does
everyone on the panel
um who was the most red flags
um Obi-Wan classic sorry was quoting
Kevin Samuels the four signs of a low
quality woman Adam's son please oh and I
read that one okay
um okay so my next question
what is a leftover woman
no no I want to hear from the men first
because they're the pickers
you want to start over there okay um
um I'll look at age
and we know that from 30 35 that's
usually big red flag
um I'll look at if the lady has kids
um
for you to have a healthy relationship
since that's what we're talking about
you have to date the woman and then
quote date the kid as well because if
you are not if you are fine with the
woman and then you are not fine with the
kid that's that's a problem and if you
are fine with the kid you're not fine
with the woman I don't think anything is
happening so that's more um variables to
consider so I think those are the two
important things that you want to talk
about
okay what do you think yeah I pretty
much agreed uh as primarily like that
age like you know what I'm saying like
because obviously guys we we want like
young women that are fertile you know
what I mean and and in their Prime do
you get what I'm saying this is a very
simple thing and then also as as my
friend here said the baggage do you get
what I'm saying because obviously as you
get older you know the woman's been
throwing books around she got a high
bloody count just naturally as she's
gotten older she slept with more guys so
her body Count's got higher you know she
she's been you know in the blender with
all different types of guys so by the
time you reach an older age bro like
she's probably going to be stubborn hard
to get along with like you know what I
mean so like the baggage and the age you
know fertility stuff like that like you
know you pretty much just leave you
there on the you know on the sideline
I'm saying so that's it
um what do you think
um well when you think about what we've
already said about the difference
between how easy it is for women and how
hard it is for men to find a sexual
partner
you've got to be pretty exceptionally
doomed if no men will choose you
um and I think the things that probably
scare them away the most are
complications with ex-partners like and
kids is a big red flag for that there
are some women with kids who handle it
well but if they there's complications
with baby daddies and things like that
that's like most men will walk away from
that I think if they're really insecure
and needy and you can tell you're going
to be dealing with their problems all
the time and they're going to be
expecting you to just take
responsibility when then clearly not
someone who takes responsibility that's
like a lot of people walk away from that
uh those are sort of the two biggest
things I can think of that would
definitely make me walk away anyway
you know I think the man who addressed
it when I first heard about the term
left of a woman I think I was reading an
article about like Chinese women and
once you hit a certain age
um and you're singled and you become a
leftover leftover woman but I think the
combination of
your age plus your mentality towards the
situation
um left a woman is a mentality it's like
you've adopted this masculine
kind of traumatic
Persona in response to your experiences
throughout the time so yeah once you hit
them ages like 30 upwards is long do you
guys think that
leftover women it's safe to say safe to
assume over a certain age they don't
know what a healthy relationship looks
like and it's pretty improbable that
they'll ever learn how to have one 100
um I think there's a book by Mike Jacob
to define a decade where she talks about
um the last part of the brain that when
it stops developing so if you don't
practice certain skills in your youth
which is like like growth mentality
reading Etc then you stay stuck in your
ways so a lot of women you hear saying
men are trash men are this and that
they're stuck in this cycle that they
can't remove themselves from because
they never practice these mental
um kind of exercises when they needed to
so once you hit a certain age and you're
stuck in that process it's game over for
you because if you don't practice
accountability and self-reflection now
when is it when is it going to change
yeah
everyone else
what was the question again
oh yeah sorry you guys can challenge
him do you think over a certain age it's
pretty improbable that leftover women
will ever be able to have a healthy
relationship because they don't know
what it looks like and how to do it I
think we've counseling and
accountability
and the willingness to work on oneself
yeah the woman can move forward because
I've seen women in their 50s
get married but that's only when they
have repented of their anger their
bitterness you know when they've
actually turned around and said you know
what I'm the problem do you think that's
more of an exception though I'll be
honest of you
especially with the whole um independent
woman those women are less and less but
I I have known women and you knows
as you said church is full of some women
like this there are women that they
realize later
but then their options are their options
but they don't have the same bargaining
power but they have gone on to get
married but they wasted their 20s and
30s doing the hurt Bay doing the Miss
Independent not taking accountability
and fighting for this cause that is just
non-existent do you think that can
happen without practice without practice
because you say that you need counseling
right or like that it can happen with
counseling but it's like you have to be
a time right but I can say I can be
okay I play I play basketball right and
I can have my coach talk to me all day
about the game
but if I if I'm not actively playing how
am I supposed to get better yeah yeah
but when you go to counseling a part of
it is they will ask you what is the what
do you what is your goal for the council
but what I see in the church is people
just like don't date because they do the
born-again Virgin thing and so like how
are you supposed to get better at a
skill if you're not actively doing it
but a lot of people are dating as well a
lot of people are dating I mean they'll
date but it's it's like more like
courting it's not like you're actually
in a relationship no I know people that
are in relationships they're not having
sex but they they do kiss they hold
hands they are they are together they
are together some people choose to have
sex some people do choose to have sex
I'm not gonna make it sound like no
one's having sex some people choose to
have sex and they end up getting married
so I'm not gonna put it out there that
no one's having sex that that would be
untrue and I do try to be honest yeah
there's people that are interested
anyone that gets married and you haven't
slept with that person before you get
married brother that's Russian Roulette
right in this day in this day and age
if you're a virgin it makes sense I
think they're both virgins it makes
sense but I think a lot of the church
teachings make sense if you're ready but
if you're based on yeah right but we're
not like the Bible the Bible wasn't
living the Bible the Bible the Bible
wasn't living in an age where the
average age of first marriage was 31. no
they won Jesus would be like where are
these grandmas
as a weigh skill for choosing a family
over going University right so the
Judgment I received yeah what from other
women it was the women judging me the
men didn't say much other women
basically I lost all my friends there
was this look of p as I pushed my pram
like I'm away skill by the end of the
day now I've I've gone to University
I've got an A teenage child and I'm
still young so at the end of the day now
you're fighting to get married so you
can have a child because your eggs are
gonna dry out didn't you say you're 33
I'm 34. that's like yeah
middle age but at the end of the day
I've still got something there's women
that are coming home to a pack of
whiskers cat food to give their cat at
the end of the day I've got a son you
know what I do think coming back to um I
think there needs to be more in schools
and about like women aren't warned
really at a young age that you have of a
shelf life and uh thank you 30 your eggs
are going to start degrees decreasing
because I have a lot of friends who are
going through fertility issues and they
you know they went and got their career
and everything and they put it on the
backbone and and I think maybe if they
knew from a young age that they would
the only reason I did it was because I
was told by a doctor you know you're
having you're having miscarriages you
might not be able to have a baby so I
went out and did that that way I made
sure I got it but if girls are given
that in in you know schools but
obviously that doesn't fit the agenda of
what they want
when I found that I was pregnant
everyone was in support of that but I
knew that I said to myself is uni gonna
be there yes
the problem is they're pushing a luxury
lifestyle an average people fake
they'll push things like IVF
which is like twenty thousand dollars
and it might work and celebrities can do
that like Kim Kardashian like that's the
example I always get is yeah and I'm
just like okay do you have the money to
be doing that I love that and do you
have the money to adopt like my parents
have adopted it's not a cheat process
and like you know I know a lot of people
that have those options and are able to
structure their life then like that but
it's really the exception it's not the
rule it really is and I think that the
Kardashians and and and a lot of um
social media social media is pushing
that you know that it's okay get your
career white you know freeze your eggs
and but it isn't attainable for most
people and you know I've got a lot of
friends going through IVF and they're on
their first cycle they'll only get that
and then they'll they'll have to pay for
it themselves and that if is if they're
in the right Borough
um wait they get it for free here you
get it for free here if you're in the
right Borough and different boroughs
have different
um ages they bail you out for freaking
everything they do but there's nothing
they don't but you can no you can get it
but I think you can have two rounds or
maybe like three rounds or something
like that but it often doesn't work it
often times
on Earth do your tax paying dollars go
to that pounds sorry
no I'm just thinking like why should you
you guys who prioritize having kids have
to pay for someone who didn't
but it makes sense they might also there
might be people who have had fertility
issues all their life and haven't met
the right person that's not the majority
of people yeah that's not the legit had
this conversation earlier this year and
the girl said well Janet Jackson had a
child well Naomi Campbell had a child
and I said do you have Naomi Campbell
and Janet Jackson money and then it
looks
more Prestige and then I had another
woman to talk about Sierra And she said
Oh but you can be like CR and get her a
guy and I said I'm not Ciara I'm not
Ciara yeah I'm a regular girl like I'm
not Ciara how can you compare us and
this proves my point what do they think
of Russell Wilson who waited semp
[Laughter]
well as a guys you guys respect Russell
Wilson no no no I like him as a
quarterback but no no yeah I didn't
float I didn't really like his choices
on that one we will never know what
happens between two people because
there's people saying that they know
people show up with a bump five months
later you will never know what someone
is doing behind closed doors I have
opened the door into what I did but
you'll never know what people are doing
and I've seen that oh so there's more
I'm not saying there's more I'm saying
there's people there's people pretending
when they have this person is there more
um
but there's people pretending to have
this perfect life and have it together
yeah and then it's only if you I worked
as a a medical secretary and it's only
when you like having someone's medical
records has changed my view on whatever
anyone says to me people could be
looking at me and saying oh she's a
[ __ ] she's terrible thrower she's for
the streets but there's people that are
Prim and popper and put together and
have had multiple diseases they've had
certain things wrong because of their
choices but you're not gonna see that so
my thing is you will never truly know
what someone has done you would you will
yeah I mean I agree with you what's your
point my point is that if we're gonna
die proper people do [ __ ] up things
all the time
like with this whole like can you what's
a healthy relationship a healthy
relationship is meeting each other at
the point of one's needs and being
willing to work through whatever it is
if you are happy to take the single mom
deal if you want a good deal on a youth
car that's you if you say you want it
brown no no bad a bad deal on a bad deal
I don't think so don't say it don't say
a good deal on anything it's a bad deal
so if you want if you want a bad deal if
you want to pay full price for a used
car okay sorry yeah yeah I've got that
if you want to pay
um
if you want a 5 000 car for a 40K
let her know DMR
yeah it's up to you yeah listen I think
there's too much talk about you like you
know oh yeah if you're a single mom you
might be able to find a guy because
there's some guys are maybe you should
shift your attention onto talking to
young girls I do not make not you
personally don't you I School them yeah
well I'm saying it should be more like
of a general thing a lot of women out
there that are in that single mother
position should be talking to a lot of
younger girls this is the reality like
and if you get to a certain age probably
you guys are not going to want to couple
up with you Mario or anything you're
going to be on your own because that is
the reality of the most out of this and
that and that's the thing a lot of them
will be homeless or they'll be their
kids responsibility and so and so it's
like the church is is teaching them to
wait and they're going to leave women
homeless
oh and that's that's the reality do you
know what I think the root of everything
is this generation has a lot of trauma
yeah and in their lives
um and we're raising
children who well in our generation that
have been traumatized in some way of
maybe their their family situation so
they are going on to have children that
are also like seeing that as a who are
traumatized because we glorify a single
motherhood yeah yeah
and there you go and and give them
bailouts in the church I'm just saying
you look at the way the benefit system's
set up in this country and I know you're
a fan of Thomas Soules so you've seen
how it works with the welfare state in
the US but here if you're in a couple
living together you get less benefits
than if you were two single people
living separately so there's a financial
incentive for people to separate yeah if
you pay more people to be single mothers
more will be single mothers 100 100 I
have a friend that's married and when
during lockdown her husband was not
working
she didn't get any help off the premise
that you're married but she needed the
help because in that circumstance she
was taking on the full burden on one
income of the household vodka's welfare
is built off the backs of men yes it is
yeah everything everything is for women
it is and yeah everything's for women
it's true I think if there was less
government support to be a single mom it
would cut down a man why said single
mothers are state-sponsored terrorists
okay I want to bring in something
um why is it that we are not encouraging
men to kind of protest these laws that
are not in their favor
there are a lot of laws because no one
cares until women no yeah because they
don't care no no no I mean like like for
example like let's talk about like if
girl
like let's let's talk about women's
issues like what like violence against
women people laugh at violence against
men and so anytime anytime men bring
their issues to the Forefront people
don't care until women bring it women
decide elections okay so I I work in um
social care so I'm in and out of
people's homes a lot and a deal a lot
with people's relationships
um usually when there's a an issue and
one of the things that I've seen over
and over again is when there's issues in
a relationship and the woman sort of
says oh she's thinking about leaving and
the social worker will respond straight
away and say yeah and I've seen on a
number of occasions when
um people who are interacting well when
I was working in support housing when a
woman's pregnant a very common question
for them to ask this woman would be are
you going to put the father on the birth
certificate you should think about not
doing that because then he'll have
parental responsibility and you'll have
all sorts of complications and I've seen
this conversation happen again and again
and again and the amount of times I've
seen social workers
failed to contact fathers uh when
they're discussing matters relating to
the child but they'll always prioritize
contacting the woman
and generally giving preferential
treatment to women in terms of contact
it is getting better in some regards
like I do see glimmers of Hope in it but
I can repeatedly see this Dynamic where
women are given the power in relation to
the child okay my point is
in back in the days it was the reverse
women had to fight to get what they are
getting today that's my point not
necessarily
yeah they did have to voice out and Men
joined them for what to to get this
support that they are getting today what
type of support suppose in terms of
um child support support in terms of the
welfare system that's favoring them
support in terms of the family cost
system that Affairs the woman yeah so
bailouts yeah but it's not like we were
discriminated against we just wanted
bailouts for bad decisions no that's
that's not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that the women had to speak up
how to rise up and a lot of men joined
that that that train that's what I'm
saying
okay
what I'm saying in this case is that
since the system is
mostly against men I believe that men
should also rise up to
and speak out against it
funny thing is that you are a lady and
you are joining us to speak out against
it so I think that we should speak out
against it but we are not most of the
time men are not are not saying anything
they will they go on podcasts like this
or go within their friends and and they
and they they talk to their friends and
that's where it ends why aren't we
taking this further into try to bring us
try to bring this up at work and see
what happens yeah
safe space to have these conversations
if a man goes into work and starts
demanding changes of this capacity they
also get the [ __ ] out of you straight
away so it's not that meant don't want
to speak out is that they can't speak up
and women women just have all the power
we decide elections
um yes I know even even in the US they
took um I mean I would assume it's
usually similar in in different places
like from the US to the UK but they they
said if um only men voted it would be
Republican like 90 of the time
because women vote with their emotions
go ahead are you saying that men
shouldn't do anything about the
situation just I think well I think I
think all groups that exist because
there's there is the term men's rights
activists and there are groups that
campaign for men's rights but often
men's rights activists is used as a slur
or a pejorative to say you know
it's used as another word for misogynist
and it isn't a misogynist and if you
look at a lot of what what these men are
campaigning for you know people like um
Warren Farrell's a really public speaker
against the sort of imbalances that uh
disadvantage men and the issues around
fatherhood and he gets branded and
misogynist but he spent most of the 80s
in the feminist movement and he's got no
issue with women and most people in the
men's rights activist Community I mean
there are in inevitably exceptions who
take it to the extreme but most of them
are saying there are women's issues and
there are men's issues why can't we
address both of them why do we just have
to talk about Whimsy women's issues and
the response they usually get is that
makes you a sexist and a misogynist and
a bigot and I'm trying I'm trying to
find it too but women get way more
funding for women's issues than men yeah
agencies that are dedicated to right
it's a multi it's like a billion dollar
industry in in that it's a billion
dollar industry that is on the bat like
the whole point is to when that women
need to be victims otherwise they stop
getting funding in fact women's
empowerment a violence against women if
women aren't victims they stop getting
funding and it's like the men they can
protest but they can't get billions of
dollars to raise awareness and fight and
they're too busy working yeah and doing
dangerous due to dangerous jobs
I'm of the opinion that if men speak out
more and support each other you see you
can see the support among among the
women is that men I feel that men need
to support each other speak for each
other we are not we are not really doing
that we are not really doing a good
I just think it's because they can't
you can't yeah they can't because as
Eddie was saying earlier I just think
there's it's a risk versus rewards some
of the opinion that men do not realize
they value that they hold in the society
I agree there is there is a problem in
which men are given a perceived value
that this is your value and and they
take it yes if they know their true
value
when a man speaks people should listen
agreed
that that's that's my take on that I I
don't think that oh because the the
people in the in the in the in this in
the company are against demands for
saying that no if everybody understands
their value in the society
when a man is saying something you
shouldn't wait on a woman to say the
same thing before you listen to the
Bible but then can I also say a
subjective this is in Europe when you
come outside of Europe oh yeah yeah this
now in Africa is not like this yeah
the Arabian world again
I've heard I get a lot of messages from
guys like all over the world and I I've
been getting more from like third world
countries saying feminism is impacting
us here it was currently better like
especially especially I don't know I
haven't looked at it in into it too much
but even like places like India yeah
where that had one of the best marriage
rates like I've heard that I I don't I
don't want to speak on it too much
because I don't know enough but I've
just I've gotten enough messages from
dudes from India that I know like
something is going on definitely is
definitely spreading
um okay so I'm gonna read the super
chats and then I'm gonna close out the
show so if you guys I'm going to read
them
all right you you too you too don't
interrupt me when I'm reading my super
chat you can give your piece when we do
the final thoughts and you can say
anything that you guys want to say all
right you too all right
um okay guys also like the video that is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out push out these streams
so if you like the streams you think our
message is important make sure you like
there was over a thousand five hundred
people in here so make sure you like the
video I think we should have a thousand
five hundred likes at least
um because the like is free it takes you
two seconds okay
um k c f shout out to Michael love your
reaction videos
um Joseph Metzler the younger generation
is less trauma the least the younger
generation has the least trauma in
history lowest poverty crime poverty or
lowest crime poverty death rates Etc
literally the safest most free time in
human history the issue is too many
options too little Struggle No purpose
Jasper proser she needs to get Frank
castled for interrupting Maurice um fiac
Pro tell the girl the reason she's
single is because the men she wants
doesn't want her or be one classic I am
legitimately not hearing anything she is
saying that demonstrate demonstrates a
God-fearing heart Lucas a virgin I was a
virgin at 26 when I met my 304 ex-wife
wasted 12 years now at 39 very happy
with my 22 year old girl from Big up
King
always work on yourself gents
um Christopher I bet if you offered body
socks 100 pounds to not interrupt for 15
minutes she couldn't do it no real man
should put up with endless barking
wizard ape gray just said
um gray just said what a man gives her
makes her proud and at the end of the
day I wonder what else a man could do
Kristoff Christopher in China Japan
South Korea left over women is any woman
single after 27 now in the west it's
probably even lower OB classic oh I read
that one already okay
um so final thoughts you want to start
Eddie
[Music]
um what can I say listen
galdem
listen to what the men them are saying
to get me because
we're not going to be able to get better
if if women develop ego the way men have
and I think that's that's what's
happening now or women are starting to
develop as much ego as men and this ego
Clash is going to create more and more
problems in society so if you want a
successful relationship start young do a
homegirl over here did date with intent
with purpose
and be be intelligent if the decisions
you're making
yeah I think as long as we treat this as
like some zero-sum game where it's men
versus women and we're always in
competition for which groups which and
then we're always going to have conflict
and if we start to recognize that men
have their issues women have their
issues and we need to work together to
deal with all of the issues that life
brings in itself then we've got much
more chance of building something
successful and building more positive
relationships and making life better for
everyone so we need to stop playing this
game where it's one or the other Amen to
that
um I would say that
for the women especially
if you don't see the example of the
ideal relationship that being
um a father and a mother in a home
working together emotionally available
cooperative and building a loving and
safe environment there is no shame in
wanting that and don't let anyone talk
you out of that or convince you that if
you want that in your 20s early 20s that
you're settling or you're missing
something out there at the end of the
day the ultimate goal is to carry on
your DNA so if you if you want that and
I encourage you to want that the less
hurt and Trauma you'll go through
because the more people you sleep with
the longer you wait it out for something
better you will just be hurting yourself
there's no shame in aiming to build a
strong family the best time to have
children is when you are young when you
have the energy when you have the
fertility when you have the youth
waiting for some rainbow in the sky when
you're in your phrase is a lie there's
nothing out there the main thing that
we're all here for is you don't want to
die alone so don't let anyone shame you
for that and Aspire for that and anyone
that doesn't want that respectfully
that's you but don't shame other women
in out of wanting that that's what I'm
saying put yourself on sale ladies
I'd say
um
go out and get what you want in terms of
be honest with yourself be honest with
the person that you're seeing that don't
waste each other's time
um try if you can to start young because
eggs do decrease and it doesn't mean
that you can't have a career but you you
need to prioritize a family if that's
what you want you need to you need to
prioritize it and I mean in terms of
what does a healthy relationship look
like I'd say you know our marriage isn't
perfect but it's healthy and we you know
we love each other and it's good
um I'd say communication is key you need
to compromise you need to have mutual
respect and trust and and keep working
on yourself like even when you're in a
relationship you still need to keep
working on yourself just because you've
got someone doesn't mean that you just
like become compliant and I've got
someone now and we're married and you
know you've got to keep working you've
got got to put the Graft in you've got
to put the hard work in and
hopefully get through the other side and
and you know you do go through hard
times but you will come out hopefully
stronger if you work it and put it in so
yeah
accountability for yourself accountable
men and women all just over accountable
even if like as a woman you see your
your girl doing something moving mad or
not hold the account we don't just like
go along with it because you're women
and Sisterhood that don't work bro
because you're just gonna all end up
single Sisterhood you know what I'm
saying men like obviously
self-improvement like be the best
version of yourself like
um like don't sell yourself short as
well don't like just put up with like
someone that don't appreciate you don't
really like you and but they're there
because they want to use you do you get
what I'm saying that happens a lot do
you know what I'm saying so like
accountability
um consideration of other people where
the other person's coming from like this
I'm saying and that's guys as well like
we have to like work together if you
want to be in a relationship then you're
going to have to work work with that
person in it do you get what I'm saying
like obviously you guys think different
to women and vice versa so like you know
you just gotta try and see things from
other person's point of view and then
obviously King rich is on YouTube make
sure you can't subscribe to that
yes he does some pretty entertaining
reactions to
um our show a lot pretty awesome
reaction
um so you guys should definitely go
subscribe
all right um I think this was a good um
conversation or discussion and um you
could see the Dynamics a female point of
view and the masculine point of view
which is very good and we need that in
this Society we need to have those
discussions and podcasts like this that
enables that that's a good idea and
please like And subscribe
um
I want to talk more to men I think that
we should be more responsible
you shouldn't take deals that are not
good for you if the deal is not good for
you it's always a good idea to walk away
I don't think it's a good idea to
continue to complicate relationships if
something is not working well just just
walk away just just walk away that's my
view on that
okay guys um thank you all for coming
good panel look at a round of applause
um okay guys um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring your
that ring that notification Bell while
you're at it like the video on your way
out that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out this
content so make sure you like a like
it's free thank you for the super chats
we're trying to save for a new camera so
we can shoot in 8k so all of your super
chats are going forward yeah yeah
I don't think we can I don't think we
could live in 8k I just went like the
reaction video you know yeah but for
reactions you'll get to see like every
Freckle but I have the whole building
I definitely won't be coming back then
so don't forget to subscribe like the
video on your way out turn on
notifications so you know when we are
live
um also follow our two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily go
follow my fourth and fifth Tick Tock
that is really important because I
really think they're going to take away
my fourth so just pearly things dot four
and just probably things dot five also
go follow my Instagram it's shadowband
right now um so that's just dot pearly
things and make sure you type out the
whole thing that'll for it to come up
and help me get to 50K don't forget to
subscribe and I will talk to you next
time